I could even this isn't much of a to
answer the question I think that can
become a superpower or not the obvious
answer is yes because eventually we will
arrive at that spot we the
transformation process is not where the
forms are really done since 91
so in there's none of the things now now
the second part of the question would be
what what does it take to be a Superman
when in the gamma supercar so what is
the definition of nuclear weapons good
roads and railways with infrastructure
the path the power facility zero power
cuts women's education equal rights and
there will alive at all those or India
will arrive at all those avenues all
those milestones going to be achieved
but the difficult the difficult question
will be how quickly because you have two
billion people the biggest problem is
possible today's last session was the
mouse problem system last five years
these problems are going to be the
crucial ones if you need to watch out
for fittest change a change is slow
we're not like China and not decay when
a dictatorship so change will be slow
what our biggest concern is to watch out
for Maoist insurgency pop and just who
knows what other problems will have come
up because of the amount of inequality
which is there in the country so we need
to see how quickly we can we can
eliminate inequality in the country well
that needs to be the key question can
India become a superpower yes that's
where I like that